Scot we spoke to you I think in 2014
right around the time of the release of
your book writing for the green light
so it's 2017 right now what have you
been up to these past few years at that
time I was working with Mar Vista
Entertainment and I actually moved away
from them and I joined a new company so
I'm now working with the company that's
uk-based called DRG they're actually
owned by a Scandinavian entity called
modern times group which owns 30-40
production companies all over
Scandinavia Eastern Europe and we manage
a lot of their you know the distribution
of that content but because DRGs
uk-based they have great relationships
the one of UK production companies
distributors broadcasters like BBC
channel 4 so we do a lot of distribution
of that content and then we do some
major co-production deals with US
entities like AMC networks NatGeo etc so
it's been great it's been a lot of fun
and I'm actually working on a new book
that's kind of same ideas writing for
the green life much more distribution
focus to kind of give people a really
simplified easy to digest way of
understanding some of the more granular
complexities of the distribution
business in a way that's kind of
applicable to being a filmmaker or a
producer or writer so what are your
day-to-day activities and who are you
interacting with during the week for
your new venture or your new role so
what I do with drg is I cover
I basically manage business development
and the sale of media content from the
UK office into North America so actually
I'm one of very few Americans that work
for the company it's really much more
European based but they wanted an
American kind of in LA on the ground who
could represent their interests help
them develop and grow and get a strong
foothold in to the United States because
this is by far the biggest media market
in the world so being able to get direct
access to the big players the the major
networks here the the major digital
players etc being able to have somebody
in town who can have that direct you
know communication was very important
for them so I handled the
the day-to-day sales of content the
finished content of the completed stuff
I helped work on development deals of
putting together new media content and I
also do what are called format deals
format deals are when you take let's say
an international show something like a
big one like shameless when that gets
reproduced in North America it's called
a format it's it's you're taking the
format of the original show and making
an American adaptation so that's you
know American Idol was a format the
voice is a format it's a replicable type
program so we do a lot of format deals -
and I also cover Latin America - in the
same capacity who are some of the people
you're interacting with on a daily basis
um primarily who I work with you know
it's gonna be acquisitions executives
that the major networks it's gonna be
acquisition executives with the major
digital platforms like Hulu Netflix and
basically I'm having you know direct
conversations with them finding out what
their content strategies are gonna be
for the channel for the platform and
helping to use the library that we have
a DRG to help them with their content
goals so I you know I'm on the phone I'm
you know doing emails in terms of
getting our content in front of the
right people and then helping to broker
those deals and then once those deals
come together you know communicating
with our london-based office and our
business affairs team accounting
materials and brokering that whole
process out so most of the content is
overseas it's you said like Eastern
European or the UK based filmmaking a
lot of it and because we do a lot of
co-productions for instance like when we
do a co-production with AMC networks you
know they're obviously us-based so
generally in that deal the money they're
putting down is because they have a
strong you know placement in the United
States they have strong output in the
United States they have the channel they
have a lot of you know different avenues
they can exploit the content on so
they'll want to hold on to the United
States or North America's whole US and
Canada
and we'll get the rest of the world the
reverse flip of that is yeah when we
have international deals HBO Europe
deals or you know some other major
network internationally that produced
content that's either in a foreign
language or is you know English but with
an accent like Australian or British
yeah we'll take that and we'll bring
that to the u.s. of the content that is
non us-based what do you find sells here
the most what what types of stories what
types of genres you know in truth it
ends up sort of being the same type of
stuff that works globally you know
people like entertainment people like
strong characters interesting you know
just interesting experiences then we
want to pull from media in a nutshell
what works the best that we have access
to because mounter x group our parent
company is scandinavian based we have a
great relationship with a lot of the
major nordic television producers like n
RK it's the biggest channel in norway
for instance and they produce amazing
content they produce these television
series that are called nordic noir x'
and they're these very dark bleak very
fascinating very rich textured stories
we have several of them we have a series
called nobel which you know we've done a
global exclusive with netflix on not
global exclusive multi territory
exclusive with netflix long we did you
know we have a brand new one called
monster that i just closed a great deal
of stars on so that's gonna be
broadcasting at the end of the year
these are films in a foreign language
I'm sorry series in a foreign language
that have great placement not just in
the United States but around the world
so almost Bergman ask sort of like you
know Ingmar Bergman's films translated
so well here as well even though some of
them you yeah like you know The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo
that was based on a Scandinavian book
that has the exact same feel style that
the
Nordic noir is have and the same reason
that book got adapted into a major
motion picture in the United States is
the same reason why the series that get
produced out of Norway do very well on
television here but also in the digital
space as well they're just great stories
they're very unique to that region of
the world and they don't really get
replicated easily it's kind of how you
know in Korea they make the Koreans and
the Japanese in general make amazing
horror films they make these great
deeply kind of pieced together
interesting paste that they're pasted
differently in Asia and it has a totally
different feel for the audience and they
also the Koreans especially there's
there's amazing television that comes
out of Korea so there's great
opportunities in truth sourcing media
content from the international world and
bringing it to the United States look at
telenovelas telenovelas are massive
there's like it's it's actually
difficult for me when I'm taking a
finished UK series or a completed
Scandinavian series and then selling
that into Latin America because
generally Europe they produce six eight
episodes of a show here in North America
were used to thirteen fifteen as a
single season and in Latin America and
Mexico Colombia some of the big
production entities down there that
they're used to like twenty six or more
episodes for a single season so it's
it's a different level of content they
they treat it differently so telenovelas
they have hundreds of episodes and then
they can sell that same content into
places like the Middle East into Turkey
where people on screen kind of look the
same and it's gonna get dubbed anyway or
subtitled anyway so it's volumes of
content it already has an audience it's
it's built in it's great for TV and it's
gonna get dubbed anyway and it's it's a
great opportunity to do a deal we don't
have any telenovelas that drg but a lot
of companies I know that do they do
extraordinarily well with that type of
genre a lot of our viewers ask about
pitch meetings and how to acquire one
how does someone get a pitch meeting you
well dear jeez a bit different where you
know we're mostly co-producing with
major networks or major production
companies so there's already kind of an
established relationship there and I
guess that's sort of the key point in
terms of how do you begin that process
how does one open the door to get that
kind of open communication with an
acquisitions team or development team so
not just a DRG but any company you kind
of have to understand what that company
wants what they work with what they like
to you know what was on rows of content
they like to work with what what getting
a sense of it who they're kind of key
clients are you know for instance at DRG
we work a great deal with you know
Netflix we work a great deal with RLJ
acorn where you know there's specific
networks that we have great
relationships with when I was at Mar
Vista with great relationships with
lifetime Disney Nickelodeon so we would
at marvista we were producing content
that was kind of catered towards those
audiences I on networks and a few others
and at drg we have a different set of
companies that we work closely with that
we just have a library of media that
works well with those so our
acquisitions team has a different
mandate than what the acquisitions team
at Deere that at marvista had and so if
you're going to go into a company and
attempt to build that kind of you know
initial let's see if some of my ideas
are going to work well and we can get
something going you have to first
understand what that company does what
it is they like to work with what media
they're actually in need of and then the
best way to get a pitch meeting is to
poised you're kind of introduction as a
way of being able to serve their needs
to help them accomplish their content
goals so like you know if they're
looking for women in parallel films that
they're looking for you know
action films you going into those
companies pitching those two scripts are
gonna be great if you if you go in
pitching stuff that has nothing to do
with their core values as a company in
terms of what they are identified with
in the marketplace
you're not going to get a warm reception
it'll probably mean it's just they're
looking for ways to satisfy finding the
content that they need so if you can
position yourself where you're kind of
answering to that need it's the best way
to get it I know with marvista we talked
about the goldmine genre and it was
women in peril or tween comedies or
things like that yes things that were
maybe lighter it sounds like with DRG
maybe that some of the darker things
like the Norwegian are is more
acceptable so it really depends again
what you're saying on finding out what
what they represent and going to that so
maybe a tween comedy wouldn't work for
DRG a tween comedy wouldn't work at all
two years ago when I was at Mar Vista
you know I would have jumped up and down
if you give me an opportunities it's
because the mandate of the company is
different there's just a different need
and in addition to dark Nordic noir Xand
you know other deep serious scripted
content we also have a great deal of
factual films you know this is stuff
that marvista that would never work but
we have a massive library of like
one-hour documentary type programs that
do amazing in the digital space we have
a great collection of game show floor
mats we have you know a great collection
of like we call a lifestyle programming
where it's like cooking and you know DIY
type stuff you know it's a totally
different library every company has a
completely different package that
they're selling to the marketplace
distribution companies to be successful
they need to be kind of brand that is
one thing or another and because you
know because they're kind of branded
that way it attracts certain types of
buyers may international marketplace
there's only so many channels in the
world there's only so many media buyers
in the world and they all have limited
budgets so you have to kind of
distribution companies that position
themselves to be different in the
marketplace and so they develop a kind
of streamlined system of this content
works really well and because we're able
to transact on it easily let's get more
of that that's kind of how they think so
to go in that's just a pitch meeting but
if you want to showcase your script if
you want to be a producer and and you
know produce content and have it you
know get hired by a company to produce
content for them you have to be able to
position yourself to that company to say
I already do stuff like that therefore I
can help you out you know what I mean
right so it almost like back engineer
where a filmmaker knows that their film
fits into this category and then see who
has distribution that's similar to their
film exactly but then can they just call
up you said that that's already
established relationships I'm just
curious that's interesting if I was a
filmmaker and and had a let's say a
northwell thriller that I wanted to have
you know looked at it sounds like that's
not the channel that's not the proper
way to go about it in terms of me
reverse engineering is exactly the way
to do it it's just if you have if you
already have a script if you already
have a film or if you just have an idea
like a treatment or anything along those
lines that you're trying to get out into
the marketplace first off if you're only
at a treatment stage I would try to
package it or you know get some other
elements in there but but going to a
distributor that is in alignment with
whatever project you're trying to pitch
that's how you begin that introduction
of this is how we can start that process
of you know being regular in regular
conversation about this topic and
potentially future ones it's walking in
the door by reverse engineering it in a
sense of I know this company works in
these two genres of three genres my
project fits that very very well
focusing on the companies that fit that
and then talking to them basically
saying look I know you produced this
stuff or I know you develop or
co-produced this kind of material I have
something very much in alignment with it
maybe we can talk about it and if it's
at an early stage like a treatment or
you know just initial you know rough
draft screenplay type thing going to
them early and kind of saying I want to
cater this for you give me your advice
or your feedback or even better if
you're a producer hey I want to produce
this you know woman in peril thriller I
want to produce this tween comedy going
to a company that works in that and
saying I'm gonna produce it I'm gonna
fund it I'm gonna figure out how to get
the money for it what I want from you is
a clear understanding of what works
what's gonna make it a great film in the
marketplace or a great product in the
marketplace and if you know in exchange
for that I'd love for you to be have a
first look at acquiring it later you
know that way or even trying to sign a
deal where they get the opportunity to
have it regardless and then they're now
they have something at the back end they
have a filmmaker who's gonna produce the
whole thing and they get to coach and
create the exact movie they want and
they're guaranteed to have it at the end
of the day you know like that's kind of
how you do it you create opportunities
for the production companies or for
distribution companies that make their
job easier and if someone just calling
up and finding the right contact I mean
like I'm sure it's it's a sort of a
delicate process into getting that
introduction because the filmmaker
doesn't want to come off too pushy
doesn't want to send an email that's
just too much information what's what's
the proper way to kind of just ease in
just a little bit that not you know with
a lot of expectation not with too much
pressure on the other person
I find LinkedIn is a great source
because everyone in the professional
world is on there
and you look for terms like acquisitions
anyone in the acquisitions Department of
a distribution company or executive
producers who work for production
companies those are sort of the
individuals tasked with making things
happen bringing stuff in and I wouldn't
if you're going to be jumping out to
people blindly they get a lot of people
pounding them all the time so that's
kind of why I go back to you can't look
at it as what can you do for me and how
can you help me make my movie you have
to say I understand your company is
looking for material like this and I
would like to help you with your search
if you if you back engineer it in that
sense
you are help you're making their job
easier you're helping them achieve a
goal it's going to help them
professionally and now all of a sudden
they're going to be a lot more receptive
to listening to you and you position
yourself differently than all the other
noise that's out there it's kind of how
you do it and from that you know don't
make the mistake of going after the top
dog at every company you know like don't
go after the CEO or the head of this or
the executive VP of that because they
are bombarded with work all the time and
that's just within the company that's
not you know you know random people
reaching out so go for juniors go for
middle managers go for people and
companies who are hungry who have more
open time and who are looking for those
opportunities to bring stuff in because
it helps them also professionally
achieve that next level in the company
since writing for the green light which
was in 2014 or 2.25 2015 okay has your
personal opinion wavered on anything in
the book that you were maybe more
dogmatic about and then since a new film
has come out or something's changed
you've actually changed your opinion on
it
no I mean only in the sense that when
you're writing a book you know if it was
a blog or something else you can be a
little bit more like this is what's
working today and right now I wrote that
book and the new book I'm working on
also about distribution I focus on
principles not rules not gimmicks not
trends principles principles or I mean
think about like engineering for
instance we sent human beings to the
moon and return them to the earth with
as much computing power on board as a
for function calculator people were to
using slide rulers at NASA to calculate
how are we going to land an object on
the moon so you think technology today
is going to you know send us to wherever
and all these other things the truth is
the principles that work in technology
today in an engineering level are
exactly the same as they were on the 60s
just different tools to get to the same
result
writing for the green lights the same
idea if you're trying to be a writer if
you're trying to build your career as a
there are certain tools that you can
have in your toolkit that are gonna
propel you and there are others that are
just gonna hold you back
those goldmine genres that I wrote about
in that book are as true today as they
were in the 60s as they were in the 40s
as they will be 30 years from now you
know sharknado is a great example of a
creature feature you see women in peril
thrillers all the time on TV you see
them all over the world action movies
with with aging stars have been here
from the beginning of the b-movie as the
second tier to a major one and they're
going to continue no matter what they
were big in the 80s and the 90s because
of video rentals and now they're big
today because of VOD opportunities it's
the keys are just core value content
pieces that every company looks for in
one capacity or another so in truth it's
as true when it was written a few years
ago as it will be in the future too and
because it's a book I really focused on
the stuff that's going to stick around
from your book writing for the green
light
have there been success stories where
people have reached out to you yeah and
it was very meaningful to see it
actually because you know it's I I got
okay
writing for the green light is not I
wrote this great script in three days
and I'm emotionally invested in it and I
want to see it on the big screen writing
for the green light is about writers who
want to write professionally who want to
figure out that great question that no
other book really answers and it's
really just how do you begin that
process how do you talk to people how do
you pitch your work and so that's why we
kind of focus on the goldmine genres
that are like the tried and tested
they're gonna be around forever type
things so the process of writing a
script or getting a job as a writer is
not I wrote the script and I'm gonna
sell it writing begins with being able
to showcase you can write writing
requires that when a production company
is in a crunch and they need a writer
who can just get the job done the first
time
and you're the person to hire so writing
for the Green Line is about helping
writers become that if that's what they
want to become so the success stories I
saw were people change their style of
writing they gave it a you know a shot
and you know one woman wrote out to me
that she read the book she wrote a woman
in peril thriller she sent it off and
was basically given a writer for hire
agreement a step agreement which was
basically we really liked your work
you obviously know the kind of genre
that we like to work with
we need this script written can you
write it give us a treatment you know I
had another woman reach out to me
basically saying I read this book I
thought it was interesting so I gave it
a shot she wrote a Christmas dog family
movie and basically she did it as kind
of a wouldn't say a joke but like I'm
just gonna spit this out and see what
happens you know so she wrote it in two
weeks and all of a sudden this script
got a lot of attention she got an agent
at one festivals and it got optioned I
don't think it's been produced but I
mean like that's the kind of thing or
it's just writing for the green light is
about those writers who find that like
there's some okay everyone in Hollywood
it feels like as a screenwriter everyone
has a script where they dabble with it
etc and the truth is most of them are
really really really good writers they
just write the wrong stuff and because
they write the wrong stuff they blend in
with all those piles of scripts in
production houses that no one takes
seriously so it's about writing stuff
that's going to elevate you make you
stand out and have your work be taken
seriously to have it get noticed that's
sort of the idea of it so I've had a
couple of other people who've had
successes one guy got a was asked to
write a treatment to flesh out a full
treatment of a story and he got a first
draft out of it it's beginning that
process so it's only been two years or
so and you know it's it's getting real
results which I love it's it's
meaningful to see that there are people
out there who are
fulfilling their goals in a way that
just never had it spelled out is how you
do it this is the a/b this is the
instruction manual for your game plan
you know you had a lot of positive
comments on Amazon and the video
interview that we did with you back it
was it I think it was more 2014 for us
but wasn't 2014 was March 2015 2015 okay
sorry I only remember that okay cuz it
was around I knew where I was I was
leaving work after shifting to dr geez
okay all right well one comment that
came in on the video interviewed that we
did which I felt was constructive
question was one lady put regarding
goldmine genre that I don't understand
something if one should focus on gold
mines on resign how do deeper more
meaningful indie movies get picked up at
film festivals the wrestler was Robert
Siegel's first screenplay
but the wrestler isn't a gold mine genre
movie it's a quote boring drama as it
would playfully describe it thank you to
anyone with an opinion on this matter I
felt it was a you know just a
constructive question totally valid
question yeah obviously there are great
dramatic films III say don't write
dramas I say don't write comedies I say
don't write a lot of these things not
because they aren't successful films
it's its most independent production
companies or distribution companies
those require a lot more work they there
are a lot more difficult and complex to
package together okay it's it I don't
know the story of the wrestler as far as
and how it came from you know embryonic
idea to how it got to Darren Aronofsky
but he's not a nobody in town sure and
if he was connected to the writer in
some way or how it got from point A to
point B I'm not visible to that I know
the other story that always gets brought
up as a Diablo Cody so when she wrote
Juno it's the same situation it's a it's
a indie boring drama as Scott describes
Howard is that possible
well she wasn't a first-time writer
she's a first-time screenwriter but she
had a very successful blog
she had I believe a book that she had
written with a manager about her
experiences because her blog was all
about being a stripper and some of the
the trials and tribulations of that so
she got a lot of attention for having a
fan base as a blogger then wrote a book
and then you know basically had this
great idea for a movie but she also had
a network of a manager and agents and a
fanbase of people that she kind of had
formulated who she was as a writer and
then had you know people connected in
Hollywood to be able to get that past
from point A to point B she's connected
she's not your newbie writer who has
zero connections in Hollywood for the
people who have zero connections in
Hollywood that route isn't the easiest
to get into so writing for the Green
Line is about getting to that point how
do you get to the point of having a you
know a collection of professionals to
speak to to pitch your ideas to that's
what it's really about
and there's all kinds of great genres in
the indie space but a lot of them are
also developed internally where you know
pre-sales are put together or production
company a has a relationship with some
major talent and that major talent
brings in a story that's very
interesting distribution company brought
on board knows how to pre sale it to six
companies and different territories on
the planet and then they hire a writer
or they go out to agencies and they find
a writer who is up-and-coming that they
can assign it to like that's kind of how
that stuff works so to get there you
kind of have first have to pass the
litmus test of being seen as a writer
that can deliver and getting yourself
kind of getting your feet wet in the
business you know that's a major leap
and you can get there and I'm just
saying don't go out of a gate writing
that stuff don't have those great films
and those great scripts of yours be the
ones you showcase to Hollywood people
because people are going to go this is
great but we've got 30 others just like
them and they're connected to other
projects that are attached to something
this one isn't so I'll put it to the
side and we'll see what happens and
usually nothing does and it doesn't mean
it's not a great script it just means
it's not attached to things so to
overcome that hurdle
the gold mines honors are this is a
great stepping stone to getting to that
level where when a production company or
an agent or whomever is looking for that
person who can make something happen
magical on the page you're the person
they call instead of the thousands of
other scripts they have sitting on file
someplace that's the idea of write in
and I know the Diablo Cody was
referenced and in one of your videos too
and what about like similar is like a
Tucker max somebody like that where he
had a blog same type of thing I don't
know if he was new to the industry but
it sounds like it's similar to that
there was already a following there and
so it wasn't just like a new beat yeah
at the gate
look the idea is like there has to be an
end user if you want people to transact
on what you're creating whether you're
writing a script whether you're selling
a product that you invented whatever it
is like if you want to transact on
whatever it is that you're inventing you
have to have people to put it in front
of in the blogging sphere today
especially with YouTube influencers and
all this and the reason YouTube
influencers are so popular is at least
on my side of the business where they
get cast and movies and stuff is because
they have an actual numerical figure
attached to their names of the people
that they reach so if you have a film
like you know camp Takota is probably
the most known example you have YouTube
influencers who in some ways redesigned
how we communicate in pitch movies to
people and get people involved early and
all that but the truth is they're not
doing anything that hasn't been done
since the beginning of time in terms of
having finding an audience understanding
what that audience wants and then
speaking to them and catering to them
honestly you're doing the exact same
thing with film courage you have a core
group of people who you know view the
videos they have a vested interest and
learning more about this business and
how they can improve their career within
it and you know when is we just did with
the Alba Cody when you ask when they ask
questions about how does this work how
does that work those are the questions
you ask people like me and like other
you know people you've interviewed to
get the answers
I've seen you say something about the
big secret that never gets told to
anyone outside of Hollywood is that most
films are greenlit before the final
script is made you know do tell because
to a lot of people that aren't from here
or aren't familiar with the business I
think they'd be sort of shocked to know
that it's important to remember that
movies and TV shows cost an incredible
amount of money to produce and if
there's nobody to watch it on the back
side or to transact upon it on iTunes or
at a movie theater then there's not much
of a point in doing that and there's
there's an even more expensive aspect of
producing something which is marketing
it and getting it out in front of people
so they know it exists so that when
they're interested in seeing it and
ready to buy tickets or download it
behind a paywall and pay money for it
they have the ability to do it and
they're ready to do it right away
so that's the financial end so people in
my position all I mean from where I'm
working all the way up to top executives
at studios
what those people the end users want to
see is really really important
and that's kind of where we're thinking
because if the end users are interested
in seeing it then international
countries would be interested in also
having access to it and they would be
willing to invest money to have access
to it early which is where the whole
presale game kind of comes into play or
you know a TV channel here in the US if
they know their audience wants something
very specific they will kind of work to
have that produced on their network and
they'll kind of work backwards
you know first finding out what kind of
project it's got to be the types of
people who have to be in it and then
working their way backwards to get to
the point of actually drafting writing
and creating and all that so on the big
scale for these major major productions
at the studio level or the major Network
level that's why they go for
like major franchises or very well-known
books or very well-known media
properties are doing remakes there's
already an audience there they already
kind of have an estimate of how it's
gonna be you know get from point A to
point B and that's where the business
side of it really plays it's what is it
how is it gonna work where's the money
coming from and who's gonna get paid
what to make this whole process happen
that's got to all be figured out before
you really hone in on the right script
most screenwriting books
approach it as you write a story and it
evolves into a movie and this whole
industry doesn't exist with people
twiddling their thumbs waiting for the
right script to drop into their hands it
works the opposite direction which is we
know we need this type of content to be
successful we have certain channels or
certain just you know platforms that we
have to cater to with content so that's
the stuff we're going to be looking for
as finished content or we'll go make it
ourselves you know that's what marvista
did really well in writing for the
greenlight ID the whole first chapter is
exactly about that idea we I used to go
to can I used to go to Berlin to the
major film festivals I'd meet with my
buyers we would have a slate of movies
that we were going to pitch and we would
see which ones had traction which ones
didn't we had a reputation for being
able to produce or deliver movies that
would get from point A to point B and be
delivered on time and be quality
productions we'd get the pre-sales first
and then we'd go back and say okay write
a movie based on the pre-sales write a
movie based on the poster we invented to
sell the pre-sales that's how it really
works content is developed from the
inside out the occasional one-off to
that or the occasional exclusion is when
major a-list talent who already have a
very well-established career come up
with unique ideas but frankly they can
walk into CAA
or a top executives you know office
wherever in town and just say here's an
idea I'm thinking of and it can be
greenlit right on the spot in the sense
that they can move forward with it
should a screenwriters start designing
the movie poster before the script is
written
I don't think so I mean I mentioned that
in the writing for green light book
because that's how we did it we already
had the established connection and track
record of being able to pre sale movies
and to produce them and deliver them and
have them actually meet the expectations
of what we promised to deliver and we
had a whole marketing department that
knew how to create poster work
specifically for the movie buying
audience you can usually tell when an
indie producer has draft of their own
artwork versus when it's done by you
know a company that's used to selling
into the movie space because it just has
a completely different look it's it's
not a marketable punchy pushy type
poster not that there's anything wrong
with it it's just that it's not the type
of stuff that attracts the buyers from
all over the world or you know things of
that nature they get redesigned and
redesigned throughout the whole process
I think the screenwriter shouldn't worry
about that stuff they're not going to be
in a position especially starting out
where they have to pre sell their
project to buyers they're selling
themselves they're not even selling
their script really they're selling
their talent too right so they shouldn't
have to focus on the marketing
components of creating artwork they
should focus on making sure that they're
you know producing a library of work a
portfolio that they can showcase that's
ideally all of the same type of genre so
they can just be the go-to screen writer
who can deliver that type of film
quickly and reliably just as as I'm
saying we would sell movies pre sell
movies off of the poster people would
pay us and pre buy them because they
knew we could deliver them there's a lot
of companies that try to pre sale that
fail I've worked with ones that were
very successful because we had the track
record of being able to reliably deliver
on time good quality products that's
what the screenwriter wants to do just
from a writing perspective here's my
showcase of what I can do this proves a
track record if you give me the
opportunity you can guarantee and trust
that I'm gonna get it done correctly the
first time so why do you think those
other titles failed what was the reason
did I have nothing David I mean you said
that there were others that tried the
same approach but other companies
especially that look pre-sales is this
really sexy fun idea of like you know I
my idea is gonna be so great I'm just
gonna get 20 countries to jump on board
and buy it you really have to know how
the pre sale process works who the
buyers are at these companies that are
willing to invest that money you have to
you know already have produced a decent
amount of content that's going to kind
of prove the fact that you know what
you're doing and you can deliver movies
on time that are under budget or on
budget that meet all the technicals
specifications of that specific country
you know it's a it's a delicate process
and it's not easy to do and not all
companies do it there's a lot of
companies I've no interest in even
trying it but the idea of selling a
movie off of a poster that really only
today happens at the pre sale stage and
not every company does pre-sales
big studios that they'll come out and
basically say this is our slate
independent companies we have to go
build those relationships because we
don't have output deals with everybody
we don't have guaranteed buys and you
know the majority of the countries of
the world the way Studios do so there's
companies that try to do that have to be
very they have to have a very good
reputation for being able to already
accomplish what they're selling
themselves to be able to do you're
working on a new book yes and it's about
distribution so it's taking the same
concepts of running for the green light
how it broke down the process of look
this is all the stuff that really
happens that's never really talked about
in books or anywhere else for that
matter about how this process really
works from beginning to end and how the
whole thing is really reverse engineered
so it does the same thing for the
distribution process it looks into
things like how do you sell a movie that
doesn't exist yes I just said pre-sales
how do you how do companies buy and sell
content that's already completed how
does how do deals get negotiated from
beginning
to end what are all the little loopholes
and accounting that you have to be
careful of and you know all that stuff
and more importantly I think is where do
filmmakers and novices and newbies and
hopeful producers fit into the whole
scheme of this what is the landscape I
think that's very important but the
thing I really focus on the most or what
I call the foundations and the
principles of distribution just as I did
for writing for the green light with the
goldmine genres these are the pillars
that basically all companies kind of
operate around we do the same thing here
you know ideas about how movies are
really valued how how rights really work
and how deals really take place what
about the likelihood that someone will
be paid up front versus on the back end
for a script for the the distribution
rights of their finished film it I
couldn't even quantify like a
probability it's uh I like to think in
the sense that buyers try to gain as
much or as little as possible and people
with something to sell try to sell it
for the giveaway as little as possible
for the most money and it's finding that
balance between the two where the deals
take place so the likelihood I would
kind of put it more in the sense of what
is it about the project the movie the
whatever that makes it worth money
remember it's very expensive for
companies to acquire content to buy
movies to even just pick them up for
free there's an incredible amount of
work they have to do on the back side to
get it market ready and to get it from
point A to point B so if they acquire a
movie for free they are incurring a
great deal of costs so they have to
weigh that in a great deal when they're
evaluating stuff and sometimes they're
willing to take a risk on a movie that
they personally like and they're not
sure how well it might even perform in
the market that would be more of an
option where they're not willing to risk
as much of their buying budget to
acquire it but if there are things in a
film if it's a gold mine genre if it's
has certain level of cast attached to it
if it's truly market ready and completed
and everything else
it might be worth a decent amount of
money and if there's some real talent
associated with it as I said like that
is what elevates movies in the indie
space first question I always get asked
by international buyers who's in it
that's what separates a movie with
nobody in it that you know probably
didn't have much of a budget versus a
movie that understands and knows how to
create content for the marketplace
speaking of which if a filmmaker goes to
AFM what should they be prepared to
answer you know when we see these
peoples pitch their startups or whatever
they it's something they have these
answers ready to go what same thing for
someone going to pitch their film at AFM
again we kind of go back to the idea of
people go to AFM ready to pitch
themselves and their content and what
they have and what they're bringing and
how great it is and they'll just go door
to door to door you know this is what I
am this is what I have me me me me me
and there's very little attention paid
to the opposite side we've all seen
these guys at bars who just hit on one
girl and then it fails next girl next
girl and you just it's like just walking
down an aisle you know one after the
other and you just hear all the doors
slamming shot and it's that kind of
concept of a producer filmmaker a writer
has to look at each company and really
understand what it is that they do they
are in the business of selling and
distributing content that is very much
in alignment with the content that the
producer the director the writer is
trying to sell they have to go into the
conversation not me me me this is what I
have to sell you how much money do you
have it's much more we seem to have a
lot in common here would there be
opportunities for me to maybe showcase
my work in case you ever need a writer
that you can call upon if you're in a
crunch the first chapter writing for the
Green Line is about that it's about we
pre-sold a movie based on a poster it
got greenlit and it at a board meeting
and then it was assigned to a producer
who's pretty new to the company and so
he didn't go to an agency and start you
know combing through scripts he didn't
go to our back room and
reading scripts from page one he called
a friend of his he knew he could write
and got the job you know the next day he
needed his script in three weeks cuz
that's when they started production he
had nine thousand other things to focus
on producing that project so he just
wanted to know the script component was
completed so when you're going to AFM
it's kind of the same idea where these
are all companies who are there for one
thing and that's they're trying to sell
their content to distributors they're
trying to get their I mean to
international distributors to broker
deals they're trying to make money for
the content that they're bringing to the
market that's what I have expensive
booths set up so you have to walk in
that door with something to offer them a
way to help make their job easier and I
find that with that approach you stand
out from the masses of people going Mee
Mee Mee Mee my script my script and you
know this company just isn't in
alignment with what I'm selling so I'm
not gonna waste their time this company
very much is and you be respectful of
the fact that at a market like that
that's not necessarily the best place to
have that conversation on the fly it's
much more of a make the initial
connection get the contact details find
out if there's an appropriate time in
the near future to have that
conversation
you wrote a blog post I think a few
years back
maybe that mentioned Tim Burton's 1994
biopic on Ed Wood excellent film by the
way yeah yeah so you say that that film
is really important because it shows
still current examples of how films get
made today any thoughts I mean you're on
a lower level but you know it in truth
like those budgets back then were
massive today you know like the kind of
films that were getting made or the
Roger Corman era of making films you
know it's um one of the things okay one
of the opening scenes of that movie Ed
Wood Christine Jorgensen story that's
what it was it was basically a
transgendered individual back in the 50s
and some flock producer was making a
film about it and so ed would seize the
opportunity walked into the door set up
a meeting with mr. Weiss and pitched
himself as the guy who had to make the
movie
and because he was so enthusiastic
because in truth he was a transvestite
but was very secretive about it and he
just understood the compelling elements
of the story that had to be created bla
bla bla bla bla and then the producers
response was more or less I don't care I
need a producer I need a guy who can
make a film in three days and make me a
profit that's all I care about and the
reason was is he already pre-sold
theaters and all of these states and and
you know needed a movie to cater to that
he needed a movie there was so many
reels long using old film terminology
that was a certain budget level that
could be shot in a certain amount of
time and he didn't care the quality he
just needed the product to fill in the
gaps of where it was pre-sold it still
happens today it's no different it's the
same concept in the indie space today of
movies get kind of pre-sold pre-created
pre developed and then they need writers
producers very creative minded people to
put that together in a short period of
time and make it happen that's the real
job of a creator is creating making
things happen getting from point A to
point B quickly and effectively that's
why at the studio level major talents
get tons of money and they receive
ridiculous sums of money for screenplays
at the studio level because frankly it
takes a lot of work and it's a very very
rare talent to be able to produce that
level so that's that's kind of why it
works that way but if you haven't seen
it I mean it for anyone in the audience
who hasn't seen it it's a great movie
very fun and the whole process
throughout you actually learn a lot of
great lessons about the filmmaking
process and even though it's from the
90s and talking about an era in the 50s
the principles are exactly the same
it still works the same way and always
will I think what about the Bela Lugosi
character is there any any same concept
it's it's an aging star who frankly was
kind of washed up at the time but it's
the same idea of yeah I think even in
the opening scene that I'm talking about
that was one of the things is that he he
later went back into the office to
secure the job because he'd written a
script in two days
and
had bela lugosi who was a star so he
basically said if you if if you need a
schmuck who can get you a movie in three
days with a star me make make me crap i
forget how he described it was very good
though and he's basically just like you
know crap with the star that's what it
was called
and that's basically Bela Lugosi was the
star who was at least a decent enough
name that people recognized that
elevated the product just enough so it
became a Bela Lugosi movie you know that
was being distribute at that point and
last but not least his efforts to secure
finance so so meeting the right person
and having to go to certain lengths to
secure financing yeah so I think there's
a massive misconception like when it
comes to financing as I kind of said
movies are incredibly expensive to
produce and people on the writing in the
directing and the producing and who want
to get their work made seem to be very
very good at writing and keeping budget
in mind and they're really good at
creating budgets and all the great
software that exists now but that
getting to that point of how is it going
to be funded that's sort of the
complicated thing in at would and I
think the hopeful thing that a lot of
younger filmmakers hope is that they can
just go to a rich uncle or dentists or
all this other stuff and just pull money
together but wherever money comes from
and it you can still get movies off the
ground using that approach at a higher
level you know if you're creating
content that's going to work for
platforms out there there are a lot of
entities that will actually invest the
money and get that so it's it's kind of
I feel like I'm getting a little lost in
it but it's like it's not as cut and dry
it's always a mystery as to where and
how funding comes together at the indie
level because there's no one way to do
it but the truth is if you're creating
content that actually has placement that
actually already has a spot to fill that
actually already has room on a shelf to
be placed there are a lot of entities
who are willing to invest the money into
it I think the real
answer is if you're going out there to
produce something that you want to
produce because you're passionate about
it and you've not done any real market
research or talk to companies about what
the market wants you're gonna have a
really tough time getting financing if
you take a step back you focus on what
the market needs what it's asking for
what companies are searching for and
then you cater to those needs financing
actually becomes a lot easier because
all of a sudden you know there's a lot
of companies with deep pockets and error
looking to invest the money they're
looking to invest it with stuff that's
going to help their goals in writing for
the green light you have chapter 4 and
that's entitled how I learned to stop
worrying and write for television yes I
love that title so can you talk about
some of the highlights of that chapter
yeah when I was sort of newer to the
industry there was always sort of two
schools of thought you either wrote for
television or you wrote for movies the
movie side is kind of cut and dry
there's the three-act structure etc
whereas televisions kind of all over the
map and what I was always taught when I
was younger was you have to write a spec
script of a major TV series that you can
kind of showcase your talent and
showcase you know how to you know grasp
how television works etc etc but in this
chapter I kind of expose television as
being very different than movies in in
the movie side I'm very adamant never
write drama never write comedy when
you're starting out if you have great
ideas for drama and comedy and you want
to write features excellent just
back-pocket them for a while and get the
contacts first televisions the complete
opposite in television you should really
focus on writing only drama or only
comedy and doing both extremely
extremely well and if you're gonna be
doing drama you want to focus on our
long dramas if you want to do comedy you
want to focus on half-hour comedies and
that's just something that's a polar
opposite of how you're gonna break into
the film side of things television is
kind of breaking some of the things I
talked about in the movie side the other
thing with TV is it's open-ended movies
have a beginning
in turn end and there is a conclusion
and there's something we pull from it
after we experience it TV needs to be
not a story arc it needs to be a
platform a strong platform built with
interesting characters who are
consistently able to be reintroduced to
each other with new beginning middle end
episodes and then reput together and
reput together time and time and time
again when best shows on TV is law and
order it does this in a fantastic way
I believe it's almost at a thousand
episodes across all the different you
know types of the show the styles of the
show but what it is is it doesn't matter
where you begin that show you can start
that show any season any episode and you
are not missing a thing there are great
character developments that take place
with the characters if you watch all the
episodes but you're not you do not have
to watch it in a chronological order if
you've missed the first five episodes
you you don't have to do a catch-up you
know if some if if you start in the
middle of an episode you can actually
catch up with where things are going
because each thing is a self-contained
you know short form movie that can just
replicate and replicate and replicate
what star Trak is it's a great platform
for a consistent endless output of
content and television isn't just that
we're thinking scripted here most
television content is non-scripted
factual content or you know late-night
talk shows
you know lifestyle programs that have
narration remember you know these
programs need writers to they have to be
organized and orchestrated and
documentaries have to be you know pieced
together
magazine shows like news programs have
to be written so for writers who want to
get a beginning start in the business
television sometimes offers really
interesting out-of-the-box ways to get
your feet wet you can go to any of the
shows that film here the late-night talk
shows and and become a joke writer
they'll pay you you know you'd submit
your jokes every single day and then you
know the pay for the ones they use
and the comedians on the shows don't
write the monologue every night it's a
team of writers that's a great way to be
on set and to become a staff writer you
know getting your work out there and
exposed and and and you know working in
talk shows or any other kind of factual
place gets you into the business of
working with these people and it's a
great stepping stone to begin working in
the scripted world as - in fact that's
how I Met Your Mother
the team behind that that's where they
came from was writing gags and jokes for
late-night talk shows and they they got
access to the studio and built their way
up from there on the personal side
meanwhile of course they're writing like
hell at night and and working and
building up their portfolio of work so
writing well though you said I mean I
know that's very subjective and and but
but some things are going to take and
some things aren't what you're asking is
what constitutes good writing and if you
write well if you are writing scripts or
stories or treatments that are just
great ideas that's all you have to do as
a writer and that's not the case you
have to get those not just - it's not
just getting those to the right people
it's not a misleading them out
eventually if I keep throwing spaghetti
at the wall it'll stick it's structured
and strategized
to be a writer you have to think about
what gets produced as I said movies cost
a lot of money TV shows cost even more
money in a sense to produce and it costs
a lot of money to market to people so
there's an audience ready to watch it on
the other side so if you are writing
stuff that's kind of catered to that or
that's when when TV shows and movies
need a writer if you're writing to be
seen as that writer who can deliver it
you're not throwing spaghetti against
the wall you're going in with a strategy
with a game plan with a with an
objective and a plan it's a it's if you
just write aimlessly you're not there's
always exceptions of course and outliers
but your chances of being able to just
like write something great and have it
get picked up and turn into a studio
movie
like it's just not going to happen but
you can strategically set up your career
in a way where you are writing stuff
that the industry needs and you will see
people coming to you and working with
you or taking your calls or asking to
read your stuff just as products today
are you know big data tells people who
their users are down to how they're
watching it who this person is their age
demographics income all that how much
did someone know their audience for
their film like how much do they really
study and shrink it down oh it's gonna
be a person in this age range this
income bracket watching it on their home
television set it's going to be at the
holidays the the truth to that and it's
great that you're bringing that up is
that's not a canoe be writer or a newbie
producer and a hopeful director that's
in truth that's the component they don't
have to worry about as much that is
where it falls more into my role or our
role in the distribution world we know
those answers we know the audience that
we're selling to we're not we're not
directly selling to an audience audience
people actually buying the movie at a
you know on iTunes we're selling to the
company in between that's placing that
movie there that's making it available
to audiences they tell us what we need
and then we kind of create content
that's going to deliver to that and
through that source a television channel
is that it's a platform that reaches
audience they know what their audience
likes they know all the metrics and
details of that audience they tell us
what they need so we know what's needed
what we need from the writer is to know
can they write are they reliable can
they hit the genre conventions well the
reason I talk about the goldmine John
Rose in writing for the green light and
then also the television chapter is it's
a great way of saying look you don't
have to you know you don't have to
overthink it hit these buckets focus on
these types of genres and even if you
make mistakes even if there's novice
errors like you know slight
inconsistencies or maybe a typo it's
gonna be okay
because there's so few people who write
that kind of stuff the stuff that
Hollywood truly needs so you know metric
hang out whether the lead female is 42
or 47 is meaningless in a way it's it's
all right middle-aged woman that's all
we need to know
woman apparel thriller got it are you
hitting the genre conventions great
we're not gonna buy that script we're
gonna hire your services as a writer to
write the script we do need we've
already figured out all that stuff and
we'll let you know about it that's how
it really works so for an individual
writer for an individual filmmaker don't
sweat that stuff that is the component
of the business that you truly can say
all that other people worry about that
because they're going to be informing me
what I need but first you got to get
over that hurdle of how you're gonna
have that relationship and to get there
focus on the goldmine genres build that
relationship get noticed then the steps
will follow that's a great point you
said that that they actually do need to
worry about because I think there's a
misconception that a lot of people oh
when I get to this level I won't have to
worry about that but then it's it's the
chicken before the egg type of thing
well at what point are you going to be
at that level so what are some things
that people really do need to pay
attention to to launch their career or
to get their work seeing that they think
they don't to be mindful of where their
role fits into the total landscape of
the business you know in distribution in
in the media business in general it's
really we're following the lead of an
audience
audiences tell us what they want and we
just have the skill sets the connections
and the ability to hear that find the
content that's going to work or find a
way to create it and then find the
people who can help us create it and
then package it and get it out to people
you know that's what distribution is and
for people who are trying to kind of
cross that first hurdle in their career
the thing they need to be very cognizant
of that and they need to be very
understanding that yes filmmaking is an
art but it is a business before it's an
art Thomas Edison did not invent the
film camera just because it was going to
open the pathways to creating great
stories he did it as a way to sell a
product and to sell visual images that
people would buy Eadweard Muybridge who
created series photography there's a
reason all the characters and his work
are nude because they needed to sell the
imagery they needed to sell the package
and in fact the the famous horse that
was running and all four legs were up at
the same time it was a bet as to whether
that actually existed so I mean the
first movie which was Edward boy-boy
Bridges running horse I don't know what
it's called
it was a transacted produced this for us
so we can win a bet that's how media
works it's here is the audience
here's the money produce something so it
fits this and we can continue that
process going that assembly line it's
very easy to criticize the assembly line
when you're on the creative site when
you're new to it you know I don't want
to sell out I don't want to just make
frivolous junk I get it but there is a
great common ground in the middle there
where there's an audience who wants
certain kinds of content and their
distribution company is willing to pay
for it and help put the financing
together and we need creative people to
jump in and make it happen and there are
amazing movies that are very very shanwa
oriented that that are great stories
meaningful and have surpassed time in
terms of you know people still reference
them and go back to them and rewatch
them and there are very very very
commercial products so you know it's a
business first films would not get
funded if there wasn't money to pay for
it and people wouldn't be investing in
movies if there wasn't a profit to be
made on the back end very few very few
I thought that was great that she said
that criticize the assembly line because
we do get a lot of comments on our
videos about that and not just the the
one and that you did about your book but
you know people that it criticized that
the comic book franchise and things like
that but the thing is is that it's there
for a reason and I'm not saying that I'm
a total fan of that genre by any means
and I get what they're saying but I
think it's a lot of times hard for a lot
of artists to accept that because they
are artists they don't want to write
just something that's going to sell and
it's it's finding that balance you know
we still need to get a job even though
we may not like doing certain things we
still need to bring in some kind of
income so it's an interesting debate the
look the greatest works of art in
history go to Europe and go to some
museums the Renaissance its commissioned
work Michelangelo was a commissioned
artist you know the Sistine Chapel was
not a vision he had he was hired to
produce it
he took his talent and his initiative to
bring life to it and to make it a
masterpiece but he was hired to hey we
got the ceiling and we don't know what
to do with it so you know you came
recommended to us you know so it's it
that's how it works and that's that's
been art from the beginning
Great Expectations this giant book we
all had to read in high school the
reason it's so giant is because Charles
Dickens had a whole family with dozens
of kids that he needed to feed and he
was being hired every two weeks to keep
an attentive audience entertained so he
said all right I'm gonna keep this story
going because I'm making money doing it
and he was being paid by the magazine
because of the magazine had an audience
willing to pay for it to keep it going
the money comes first if there's not
money there if there's not something to
be transacted upon on a profit to be
made there is no art there's nothing to
be created because no one's going to pay
for it except a couple of wacky people
who are willing to sink money into some
projects but if you want a career and if
you want to get to a point where you can
express your artistry you first have to
know and prove more importantly prove
that you can actually get the job done
in the first place so is there a way to
soften the sellout label it's been
bandied around so much and I get why
people go there but I feel like
sometimes it's it's overused my opinion
is that like selling isn't selling out
selling out is sort of when you like you
just throw in a towel in a sense like
you you how do I say this
working in a way where you are creating
stuff that matches what audiences want
is not selling out you can still look
there's still so much you know latitude
you can have with a script with a story
even if you're working in the convention
of woman in peril thriller or aging male
action hero film you know like there's
that's just that's an architecture you
know like the great alright I've used
this reference before and some other
interviews I've done like like great
architects have rules they have to
follow there's gravity we have to deal
with that fact we have to deal with
building codes we have to deal with the
costs of creating the structure you know
it's not an open-ended budget the bridge
has to serve a function it can't just be
something artistically and architectural
be profound there has to be a purpose
for it and there has to be a reason why
it's existing what makes it art is what
you do with that how much of yourself
you put into that so getting to a point
where you were presenting yourself to
the market and saying I can do this
stuff and I can add a spin to it that's
not selling out but selling yourself
that's building your career and that's
getting you to a point where you're
actually going to have clout you're
gonna have connections you're going to
have a track record you're gonna have a
whole history of films or projects that
you've been associated with that I've
been successful commercially viable and
then you can cash in on some of those
great connections you have and say I
want to do something a little bit
that's why I always go back to the cold
mines on rus' I say don't write drama
don't write comedy what I mean is don't
write them out of the gate if you have a
great idea
keep it on the back burner for a bit
because once you build your career and
you have connections you can then take
it off and say look I know I'm known for
this kind of thing but we have a great
relationship and what do you think of
this you now have opened that door to
create something fantastic and forget
most of the film directors that are so
well renowned today look at where they
began I mean look at how many careers
Roger Corman started you know it's most
great talents you know don't rush out of
a gate with masterpieces and Robert
Towne who wrote Chinatown also wrote
Days of Thunder like this is just the
way it is it's a business and we all
have to pay bills and selling selling
yourself and being paid for your work
and having a successful work is nothing
to be ashamed of frankly people that
feel that way or want to throw that
label around probably aren't going to
get too far they're shooting themselves
in the foot right why do you think
people go there with that label I mean
it's easy I think it's I think it's
really really easy I think it's really
easy to cut others down I think it's
really easy to call anybody who's doing
something that is slightly commercial a
sellout
you know label them because god forbid
they might actually become a little bit
successful doing it I think it's also an
easy way to cover up for one's own
insecurities about their own work I
think that happens a lot too he's a
sellout she's a sellout you know
whatever it's like well how was your
work gonna get from point A to point B
frankly I don't know too many people in
boardroom meetings talents when they
come in to pitch their work who have a
really pissy attitude I don't really see
them get too far it's usually much more
of a collaborative conversation it's
usually much more about how can we work
together how can we do this what do you
need in the story being
being receptive of notes and feedback
you know those are people that do well
in life and do very well in this career
the people that sit there going no it's
my way or the highway and you don't have
a track record of anything behind you
like who's gonna invest in your project
frankly it's just night thank you
there's probably there's always an
outlier a one amazing script it's once
in a blue moon but to be honest I've
never heard of it or seen it I'll keep
my eyes open though okay what thoughts
do you have on DIY release strategies
the I guess the criticism I get a lot of
the things I hear from people all the
time are I don't understand that
businessí stuff and I don't I don't get
the distribution stuff and you know it's
always I'm gonna focus on making my
movie and somebody else will deal with
all that truth is today it's never been
easier to produce a movie or any type of
media content in general the technology
is fantastic the costs have dropped
tremendously and anybody can do it the
problem is because anybody can do it
there's tons of it and so it's more
important I think now for filmmakers and
writers to be cognizant of what is
needed in the marketplace and how that
whole end process works and the great
thing is that there's never been a
better time in this industry for people
to do it all on their own anybody can
create a website anybody can create a
blog anybody can build a fan base using
social media platforms anybody can you
know spit out and leak information about
their title and build up an audience and
build up an interest and have that
magical moment when the product is ready
to be released already have a great
collection of people out there willing
to buy it so it's a I guess my view on
it is it's just there's never been as
much power in the hands of individuals
and individual content creators as there
has now and I think that's only going to
increase so I think the ability to take
a project an idea from beginning to end
cheaply effectively with very strong
results has never been more in the power
and
visual filmmakers so for those people
who want to do their you know project
that is outside of the conventions of
what I talk about in writing for the
Green Line they certainly can and they
you know should pursue what they want
but if you still produce within the
genre conventions I write about you're
gonna see a lot more traction I think on
the professional side because that's
gonna stand out a bit that they were
able to put a project like that together
make a bit of profit on it for a very
cheap budget that's somebody who can
prove to themselves we can bring them in
and and you know they can shoot films
for us or write films for us or whatever
what can filmmakers learn from the app
world metrics
I think the incredible amount of data
and metrics that go into engineering an
app and how targeted and focused it is
for a very specific audience I I think
that's what filmmakers can take away
from the app world what that opens the
door to is you know the genre
conventions I write about and writing
for the greenlight are good on a grand
scale but some people want to produce a
documentary that's very focused on a
touchy issue that's maybe only important
to a very small minority of people
that's fine they can exploit as much of
that small percentage of people as
possible if they focus it and target it
and reach out to those individuals and
communicate with them same thing with
like faith-based content you know
there's a there's a great audience out
there and the stuff that sometimes gets
produced on it on a grand scale isn't
hitting the nail on the head the way
that audience wants it and so they can
kind of do it themselves it's I think
what we can learn from the app world is
how much data we have and how many of
the answers we already all have in our
pockets or purses and just with the app
world beta testing something can a
filmmaker really do that with their
movie it's tough to beta test a movie
beta testing is is I think much better
at platforms and and audience response
and because of that once you kind of
make a movie it's sort of one and done
and it's either going to resonate or
it's not so you can take as many step
is possible to enhance the ability for
an audience to be receptive of it but
it's a thing where you kind of got to
know the audience in advance and that's
why the distribution assembly-line kind
of works the way it does where it's all
reversed engineering it starts with the
audience and builds back to what movie
should be produced versus producing the
movie and then just hoping for the best
that it gets to the right audience when
a filmmaker is making their movie what
should they keep in mind regarding
making it and making sure that they get
it a distribution deal are there things
that they should target making the film
changing certain scenes that they know
that distributors are gonna want let's
suppose they have their goldmine genre
they realize what they're making and who
that audience might be but in terms of
securing a distribution deal
those are certain things they should be
aware of in making a film there are a
lot of them aren't the obvious things in
the sense of film makers for the most
part tend to focus on the movie the
movie the movie and some of them the
more astute ones will definitely put
some time into trying to find a name
talent to put into the film but there's
a lot of paperwork and a lot of other
details that go into the delivery
process of getting a movie to a
distribute it become very important
having all your agreements in place with
your talent having all you know
locations cleared having you know
copyrights to everything but also having
things like music cue sheets transcripts
there's a lot of these fine details that
are in what are called material delivery
lists which are basically when you sign
your movie over all the stuff you have
to give to the distributor's so that
they can extrapolate and make any create
any any type of file spec that any buyer
in the world might want you have to be
able to give that to them so that
they're not incurring any costs on that
back end that's really your job as a
producer the old vision is you know the
el Mariachi you know I can make a movie
for seven eight thousand dollars and
sell it and while that's true that that
sort of happened it was also a long time
ago and more importantly the company
that bought it how do
invest a lot of money in finishing it
and completing it and getting the audio
fixed and getting the image fixed and a
lot of that stuff to make it market
ready companies aren't willing to do
that anymore because the model of supply
and demand there's a ton of supply and
there's focused demand so maybe if you
nail that demand they'll help you out a
bit but it's not gonna be much and so
you really have to be you know aware of
what's your responsibility to cover and
there's a lot of great resources on it
if you just google around so music cue
sheets and transcription so with the
transcription is someone just
transcribing into English and then
they're taking that file and then it can
be easily done into any other language
correct like in addition to that so it's
like it's not the shooting script it's
actually the verbatim word for word what
is said but more importantly there's
timecode on the page so you have a
ballpark of what time in the movie it's
being said and that's for subtitling so
that when they translate all the
subtitles all those cues they know about
where it's supposed to hit in the movie
when they're creating it there's also
things like when you're doing the audio
mix doing what they call M&E tracks
where you separate out give your stereo
mixed tracks and then you have these
other two tracks that are all of the
sounds and music of a movie but if
you're watching it and you just have
those two audio tracks playing every
single time somebody speaks their mouth
moves and no words come out and that's
because we've wiped out all the audio
and the reason is so when you dub it in
a foreign language
they only dub the audio the verbal they
don't have to dub the whole movie and
remix the whole movie they just dump in
the voice interesting okay so you think
you got to make it ready for that kind
of stuff that kind of thinking because
that's the way distributors think right
and then the music cue sheet what would
that be about a music cue sheet is a lot
of Broadcasters internationally every
single time a music piece is used that's
affiliated with you know BMI ASCAP or
one of the you know
whatever you call them the Union so to
speak that the artist is given their
fair share of the royalty because their
music is being used to sell a product
okay so these are all a lot of it's
legal a lot of its documentation a lot
of its just stuff that you kind of have
to showcase again not to protect well
you should have it to protect you and
you're making the movie but also to
protect the distributors that they know
they can engage with your project in the
marketplace and they're not going to
have any issues later on